aujourd'hui au programme quand je
voulais me ici vous pouvez utiliser la
commande player on va parler de tout cas
on va parler de degas de la bicici qui
sont donc et une à aimer john une des
plus grosses conférences où il ya entre
autres duke vous avez north carolina
vous avez insisté vous avez notre dame
vous avez clem 5 vous avez vous des
states voilà plusieurs gros programmes
dont on entend souvent parler tu as
envoyé des jours à la draft
et on va aujourd'hui traités de cartes
dupriez exprès de garde inquiets junior
3e année à londres et williams qui joue
à wake forest politiken timmons donc de
wakfu est ce qu'ils ont vu passer paraît
pas très longtemps il y as arbres qui
qui partent du côté de kentucky et on va
parler aussi de pelé quitely qui est une
grosse hype qui est une grosse cote
qui lui tint freshmen qui plaît beaucoup
à certains mondes d'envergure alexandre
par exemple est totalement amoureux de
ce joueur alors alexandre ces papas du
du podcast envergure et c'est un fan
invétéré de notre-dame donc
il nous est dit regardez blake whisky et
du coup j'ai fait j'ai fait j'ai fait ce
que le patron m'a demandé et bien on
voit blake top 10 à 120 km top-10
certain qu'il le maître loterie certain
qu'il le mette fin au premier tour 20 si
on regarde un petit peu est ce que ça
dit chez envergure parce que ça c'est
l'intérêt alors on reste maintenant le
big board et je vais vous prouver ma
tête pour m quand même quelque chose de
plus intéressant ici normalement vous
avez le pic porte qui s'affiche
alors j'ai un petit peu de télé sur mon
propre écran mais ça devrait être bon
notre ami bhl equity alors pour
l'instant vous l'avez 22e au consensus
22e ans quand on sait ce qu'est ce que
ça veut dire tout simplement que vous
avez cinq ports de différent à celui
d'alex manu ben al ain et moi même heure
notamment que nico fasse le sien est ce
que nico est un homme très occupé qui
mais il se penche dessus ils commencent
à rentrer des joueurs dessus et donc en
moyenne le joueur tombe en 22e position
maintenant si on regarde où est ce qu'il
est c'est chacun europe je vous envoie
si vous voulez faire la vôtre tambouille
par vous même vous l'avez en 14 chez
alex vous l'avez an 18,3 que ça c'est
num notre ami ben il nous l'est mais en
12 à la ligne bleue mais en 16es -
est-ce que je voulu mais je crois que je
voulais me dans mon premier board parce
que je suis un fanatique moi j'ai pas
dis dans mon premier board
c'était trop tôt vous voyez je les fais
ya en moi et je vais le mettre à jour et
globalement si je le fais si le med i va
être fin de premier tour d'accord donc
vous avez un mois je vais être moins en
amour que lui tu incarnes mois en amont
sur lui que peu beaucoup d'autres mondes
d'envergure si on regarde un petit peu
ce que les gens disent
alors on l'a et freshman vous avez un
article qui a été déjà fin scouting
report qui a déjà été écrit par steve
qui est le spécialiste
envergure sur l'aef ici donc vous avez
l'astv boyer n'hésitez pas là il faut
l'eau sur sur twitter parce qu il nous
régale avec ses boutiques à la porte
qu'est ce qu'ils nous disaient ils nous
disaient qu'on prend forme en profil
athlétique donc il est fait un jour vous
voyez qui est long à mettre 96 de 110 cm
d'envergure donc une belle aux wings
poèmes 83 kg donc encore en profil léger
pour l'autre élément défend on a un
joueur qui est très très jeune vous
voyez que c'est un joueur qui est
capable de nous distille de créer un
écart créer une séparation ce qui est
important pour important de bâle est
capable paloma de pouvoir créer un écart
pour prendre un tir corinne à
mi-distance potentiel défensif et le mot
potentiel est à prendre en considération
dans les points moyens le play making sa
capacité à créer du jeu collectivement
la puissance du joueur
donc est ce qu'il est capable
d'encaisser du contact de mètres du
contact et de prendre le dessus c'est à
dire d'aller au panier et de ne pas se
faire arrêter dans son dribble d'aller
au cercle et de provoquer des fautes de
finir avec la faute sur deux choses là
dans les points faibles l'efficacité
dans le drive et les lancers francs
je vais pas vouloir le scouting report
en détail il est sur le site vous avait
calé sur up envergure point c'est au
vous trouvez tout ce qu'il faut
mais dans les
points qu'il faille mettre qui va être
mis en avant c'est attaque le cercle
avec peu de réussite et remonte
d'agressivité il peut créer de la
séparation
dans les situations de drive and click
et intensité défensive et lui quand il
écrit ce scouting report était au bout
de onze matches actuellement je crois
que notre dame et faudra me confirmer
dans le le chat mais jouer je m'aime je
vous le dirai si j'aurais digne
doit-elle de ma toile il a joué 25
matchs no d'astarté 19 très très vite
issartel dans le cinq majeur avec un
bouton de 28 ans real et des stats un
peu plus un peu plus précisément et donc
les pourcentages qui donne ici on va
peut-être pouvoir les mettre un peu en
mai les mettre à jour d'accord
est-ce que ce soit la cuisse leigh sera
donc vous avez déjà retrouvés sur des
grosses de deux mots coupés vous c'est
un mec qui vous est pour le coin connu
vous me dites qu'il s'agit mais en même
temps
quand on fait le profil d'un joueur en
stream souvent au regardeur la voir les
stats pour les habitués ont fait d'abord
les stades brut les stats avancés avec
les outils que j'ai ici et après on
passe au fils ont ce talent brut qu'est
ce que ça dit il joue 28 minutes par
match sur 40 possibles qu'il est
titulaire on a vu qu'il s'est installé
avec un temps de jeu qui croise au fur
et à mesure il prend 12 tirs par match
c'est le plus gros vus le buteur de
l'équipe donc c'est déjà un joueur qui
dans une étude de notre dame
à ces jeunes a su s'installer a su
prendre les devants aux termes
d'efficacité on a une efficacité moyenne
à 41% on va lui être honnête ce qui est
moyen pour pas dire assez léger qu'on
regarde un petit peu la répartition vous
avez sept tirs à 2 points tentés 40 % de
réussite
tu l'as déjà vu jouer tu l'as déjà vu
jouer en vrai ou tu l'as déjà vu jouer
en
commentateur en replay tu me dis si tu
l'as vu jouer en vrai c'est
parce que je sais qu'on a
notre dame france qui nous sur twitter
et je sais pas te retrouves c'est toi
peut-être que je te dis peut-être que je
dis des bêtises ou pas mais si tu l'as
vu jouer en vrai ça m'intéresse pas mal
de voir le ressenti de réussite et même
si tu l'as vu arriver qu'est ce que t'en
as pensé
c'est le sauve est oblique mon coup de
coeur cette année avec perdu john hayes
vie ouais ça fait un beau bac courte 20
boba cours de bien sexy bien
charismatique
tu l'as vu en vrai à l hyper intéressant
bah ouais choisie elle n'hésite pas à
dire dans l'hudson ce que tu en es ce
que tend à penser leurs sentiers tout et
on est comparé avec la vidéo que je vais
montrer et
je suis allé voir notre dame chez un
pote là va trop bien bah écoute y perdra
terre sont bas n'hésitent pas et je lis
si je réagis pas directement jeudi tout
et je reviendrai dessus après trop bien
voir un sport en vrai de façon c'est ce
qu'elle ne sait plus difficile de scout
est en réelle je trouve pour avoir local
l'occasion de le faire notamment dans
notre championnat local avec le paris
basket de l'asvel et tout ça mais hyper
intéressant donc on disait 48% à 2
points on va voir cas beaucoup de me
distancer à trois points et un beau
volume de prix cinq tirs tentés par
match est pour l'instant une réussite
assez faible 31% ces civils nous dit
qu'un peu de lancers francs tentés on
est à quatre lancers francs tentés par
match ce qui est correct ne fera guère
d'évolution le soufre is you wait c'est
surtout ça qui va qui va être décisif et
très peu efficaces 64% lancers francs ce
qui est assez dégueulasse on va être
honnête après à côté de ça
on a 3 rebonds
3,3 points 5 rebonds 2,6 passes une
virgule de style de turn over donc on a
reçu assistant dover à à à peine deux
fautes par match là c'est un peu pour le
pour le profil statistique brut ce qui
est pas très intéressant mais toujours
bien à faire avant d'aller sur les
cintres avancé et le film tu nous dis on
dirait que c'est facile pour ses
adversaires le conteste quand il drive
il croque un peu à trois points battus
vous m on va être assez d'accord toi et
moi et on va essayer de regarder ça
après jour du jour du film
globalement à leur faut prendre en
compte que le joueur est très fin
d'accord et pourquoi est ce que j
envergure il le met aussi au nez copain
alex alan et ses terrasses balcons et
chora ce qu'on appelle de la très draft
c'est rare un processus un phénomène qui
on voit de plus en plus ou vraiment on
va aller chercher des joueurs très haut
pas prêts du tout pour les laisser en
développement dans une franchise nba
n'en deux ans lui les profanes la
g-league et à ce moment-là exploiter
leur potentiel plutôt que les laisse à
la fac l'an dernier par exemple vous
avez joshua prix moquer drafté le tri
par
par sony san antonio alors que personne
n'avait dans son top 20 voire même au
premier tour parce qu'ils n'étaient pas
prêts on pensait qu'elle allait faire
deux ans on est vraiment sur ce
processus de pré draft donc aujourd'hui
est ce que blé quitely est un jour de
top 10 non mais le pari de dégâts
d'envergure des autres cadres véreux
coeur moi je quel moi je ne rejoins pas
particulièrement mais que je peux
entendre c'est de dire que d'ici deux
trois ans une fois qu'on aura développé
son corps et qu'on aura mis un peu plus
de ce qu'ils lisent avec un staff nba ça
pourrait être un joueur du niveau de
loterie et un jour qui devient dominant
regarde les stats avancé vous avez ou
mat ici donc si je voulais le faire avec
moi
vous avez les deux sites à prendre
excusez-moi up bohler je me trompe
voilà vous avez les deux sites dont vous
avez loupé maths qui est ce site là qui
vous donne la répartition des tirs d'un
joueur dans chaque secteur vous avez les
tirs près du panier le nombre de ter qui
prend près du cercle le nombre de deux
points l'ont bouclé mi distance ici et
le nombre de tirs à trois points en
pourcentage sa répartition et à chaque
fois vous avez son efficacité dans ce
domaine et est ce que le tir et issus ou
non d'une passe décisive voilà c'est
quelque chose d'assez facile et que moi
j'aime beaucoup utilisé alors il se fait
pas souvent contré mais souvent quand il
va au panier
il se fait bouger salut aux attentes et
une finition casse-gueule ouais je suis
d'accord avec toi je suis d'accord avec
toi est ce qu'on va essayer de montrer
tout à l'heure
alors par sa répartition à blake weasley
steve il nous disait beaucoup de mi
distance effectivement on voit 46 tirs à
mi distance et en trois sets 7 6 à trois
points non je dis des bêtises pendant 43
passes en 17 tirs à trois points
excusez-moi 25% à mi-distance 31% près
du panier on est redevenu sur une
distribution un peu plus être bien peu
plus classique avec un peu moins de 1000
renditions été pris
quand il va au panier
55% au cercle va ne pensons pas décisif
ça veut dire que globalement dans 80%
des cas ils se cassent son propre accès
au cercle quand il va au panier il ya
assez peu efficace 56% c'est assez
faible au niveau n 6 on y voit une pièce
est bien un peu mieux contre des adultes
mais en est ce ici
56% saft est assez faible le joueur on
rappelle
encore une fois excusez moi il fait que
83 kg il est très très jeune ceci
explique peut-être cela on verra dans le
film la mi distance donc 39 %
d'efficacité à mi distance ce qui est
bien ce qui est intéressant ce qu'il a
fait du développement de tir sachant que
dans 95 % des cas c'est du poulet c'est
un joueur qui aime vraiment se crée un
décalage qui est assez explosif inscrit
un écart équivalent à prendre des tirs
et ce quelque chose d'efficace être
capable de se créer un écart est de
prendre des tirs même avec une
efficacité moyenne et c'est à ce qu'il
ce qui est trés value et par les scouts
nba ça veut dire qu'on a un joueur qu'on
va pouvoir développer derrière qui va
pouvoir faire du choc making à mes
distances mais à trois points mais à
trois points aussi or nous donc ça c'est
peut-être son plus gros point fort son
plus gros argument de vente dans le
scouting réponse de steve si vous le
regardez vous voyez qu'il était à 50 %
de réussite ça quand même bien baissé
pourquoi parce que les défenses ont eu
le temps de s'adapter l'éléphant sur le
temps de scouts et
contrairement au début la nous c'était
un freshman que personne ne connaissait
qui était pas hyper côté et du coup on
est l'adaptation et notamment une
adaptation sur le fait de l'orienter ma
gauche ce qu on pourrait avoir droit de
la vidéo et quand il est orienté main
gauche il est bien plus en difficulté
donc il est poussé chaude est sir
compliqué donc il est en baisse en
réussite c'est pour ça que entre le
onzième match et le 25e match vous avez
perdu 10 % d'efficacité sur ce
secteur-là
à trois points enfants donc un gros
volume à trois points cette fois ci
majoritairement catch and shoot c'est
pas un joueur qui dans l'eau face notre
dame va beaucoup poolers hubble qui a
beaucoup prendre le tir derrière un pick
and roll il est souvent mouvement et
l'ema elles sont prêtes il est à 31 3 %
de réussite seulement donc c'est assez
faible maintenant on a vu qu'il y avait
un volume important il y avait une belle
réussite à mi distance donc on pourrait
se dire que à terme il devrait me
rentrée devrait mettre dedans ils
devraient rentrer plus de tierce à un
projet si vous achetez blé goudé vous
croyez en sa capacité à mettre des tirs
à trois points maintenant il ya un
problème on voit 64 5 % de réussite aux
lancers francs le football est il est
pas trop mal
on a 30 % c'est-à-dire c'est un joueur
qui fait quand même tombés des fautes
sachant qu'il va assez régulièrement au
panier donc 31 % des cas
globalement à chaque fois enfin une fois
qui va au cercle soit il va trouver la
faute suivent à mettre un panier et donc
ça c'est une stat qui est plutôt
intéressant maintenant la voulons mettre
dedans voilà donc c'est assez pour le
profil des statistiques
avancées on pourrait utiliser ou
d'explora mais j'ai pas non plus envie
de vous noyer dans les stats au début
donc bon je me garde de côté pour pour à
l'onda souilem si on va directement
passer à la vidéo voilà si vous avez des
questions des remarques et tous
n'hésitez pas clairement on peut prendre
le temps pour ce joueur alors
qu'est ce que je vous ai préparé
pour que ce soit clair pour que ce soit
simple et que ce soit assez joli je vous
ai fait de 4 playlist on va regarder
une playlist sur blake whisky quand il
est balle en main quand il va driver au
cercle balle en main tout seul une
playlist sur les cuisses léon pick and
roll parce que on espère qu'on le draft
aussi aux avoirs importants de balle
primaire ou secondaire qui va pouvoir
jouer du pick and roll ce qui est le
système le plus utilisé en nba encore
donc comment il gère le pick and roll
est qu'au moins 10 sieverts son dribble
comme moyen géré son tir son accès au
panier et surtout la passe aussi pour
les intérieurs ça choque notre dame a
pas un pivot dominant
on va regarder sans que sa capacité à
tirer au catch and shoot et ampoules up
et enfants ont regardé sa défense voilà
on va commencer tranquillement sur blé
cuisse leigh balle en main leur au début
je vais laisser la playlist la playlist
tournée on va regarder devant et je vais
laisser l'équipe comme ça pendant que je
devais décrire ce qui m'intéressait ce
sujet ce joueur est ce que j'aime un peu
moins et puis après on fera du du clip
par qui tout simplement fera du ralenti
etc vous connaissez un peu la formule
alors je vous ai dit c'est un joueur qui
est pour l'instant assez léger et donc
on le voit dans son drive que on va
qu'on va lui mettre du contact il va
galérer à pouvoir finir il ya un galet
va pouvoir aller au cercle en encaissant
le contact c'est un joueur qui est pour
l'instant très latéral dit des choses à
ma droite qui va vraiment être très
fluides explosifs sur la main droite et
qui gère bien sa vitesse capable de
tanger de cavale changer de vitesse
c'est-à-dire ralentir accéléré dans le
drive qui a une très belle allonge donc
il peut en quelques pas vraiment secret
un accès au panier qu'ils avaient très
longs bras pour aller chercher des lay
up très long
il est capable de changer de direction
de danser les iob quand il est près du
panier en l'air même s'il a encore une
fois la main gauche elle reste un peu
faible et finalement au fur et à mesure
les défenses sont rendu compte que si on
l'envoie main gauche il y avait pas
toute cette panoplie donc les défenses
maintenant l'orientent main gauche où il
n'est pas capable d'accélérer où il
n'est pas capable de gérer du contact et
que vous la finition elle est quand même
beaucoup moins bonne que fait le jour
pour compenser ça est ce que vous allez
voir est ce que vous voyez ici un spin
move on va partir très souvent sur la
main gauche sur la main droite on va
utiliser un spin move pour replacer sur
l'autre main et soit poule up avec un
petit fils de wade qui maîtrise très
bien soit pouvoir allait finir au cercle
si vous lui mettez actuellement un
contact assez haut et vous tenez
latéralement c'est un joueur qui est en
grande difficulté vous allez pas avoir
de grosses hyper explosif c'est un mec
qui fait très bien des systèmes back qui
va très bien faire des poules up et qui
va pas être capable de se faire un accès
au panier de façon de façon fluide en
changeant de direction
comme on l'a dit en termes de gestion de
contacts il n'est pas encore prêt si
vous le draft est actuellement
aujourd'hui vous lui mettez un ou deux
ans de masse musculaire
pour pouvoir être bien plus efficace à
ce niveau voilà tout simplement
je crois pas avoir grand chose de plus à
dire sur son sur son triple comme ça
comme on l'a dit premiers pas explosif
de la longueur capable de se créer un
écart mais une grosse difficulté main
gauche maintenant on va la regarder ça
un peu plus dans le détail un peu plus
au ralenti je vous ai mis des cliques
autres équipes de différents niveaux
vous avez du dew que vous avez du
notre-dame et vous avez dû exister voilà
donc vous avez un
howard et demi c'est donc au world est
une équipe de managers assez assez
faible juke cette année c'est un gros
programme avec des joueurs puissants des
joueurs forts vous avez trouvé qu'ils
par exemple sur les postes arrières et
alors qu'on vient de d'avoir un info
l'eau je crois merci beaucoup c'est très
gentil de ta part merci à toi j'ai qu'il
nous faut c'est super sympa ta part
merci beaucoup et wayne système qui est
une équipe avec des athlètes mais qui
défendent peanuts donc ça laisse des
espaces pour les cuisses mais
on est parti donc là au début sur le
premier j'ai pas non plus vous mettre
trois lieux ralenti c'est juste de la
transition le joueur est capable de
monter c'est pas un athlète verticale
peine menace aérienne de très haut
niveau et les communes comme de monter
au cercle là vous l'avez sur de la
transition de rythme à droite on aime
beaucoup cette longueur je vais la
remettre ici ce qui attire avec les
cuisses lycée ses longs segments rappel
de met dix d'envergure donc très
facilement avec de la longe hop ici je
suis capable d'aller chercher un lay up
très lointain et de protéger ma balle
avec la planche
départ main droite encore une fois de la
longueur et un lay up
main droite après contact encore une
fois ici
et ce que j'aime particulièrement cet
extrait c'est quand je vous dis changer
de rythme vous allez l'avoir ici hop je
frise je ralentis ma vitesse pour
laisser passer le pivot je vais mettre
encore plus l'enjeu ralenti ma vitesse
pour laisser passer le pivot et pour
éviter le contre hop je change de
direction en l'air et je termine avec
mais l'efficacité
maintenant
quand vous dites le jeu ryong de
puissance on voit ici donc là vous avez
une accélération mais il se fait contrer
au sart parce que même s'il est long on
voit que son corps il est en retrait par
rapport aux au protecteur de cercle qui
rentrent pas dans le protecteur de
cercle pour mettre du contact et finir
avec la photo à six et sept longueurs
pour essayer d'éviter le contact à
maximum est donc très souvent cette
année va se faire contrer au panier
comme ça ce qui explique et 55% de
réussite seulement
donc là vous l'avez en départ main
gauche
on revient sur la main droite et je
finis au sarc encore une fois même si
main gauche il est moins bon il ya un
départ explosif qui lui permet de créer
une surcharge
et quand je vous dis on ses deux
protégés la balle un maximum avec ce
jour avec de la longueur rhône dans ce
genre de situation la face à jérémy roy
qui est un bon défenseur initiée
alors on va remettre en vitesse normale
donc là le joueur
s'appuie sur sa main gauche vous voyez
les orienter - gauche on va le renvoyer
le cac peut changer de direction il
oriente main gauche il a des bons
fondamentaux de pied capable de créer un
écart et on finit sur un petit fait du
web move qui maîtrise parfaitement
parce qu'ils ont encore une fois le même
si les boues au dessus il n'est pas
capable de pouvoir terminer en drag main
gauche auxerre qui sait qu'il va être en
plus en difficulté donc très souvent on
repart sur un petit fait de wella vous
l'avez encore sur des poules up quand il
les conteste on va leur mettre ici
donc là il va switch par un ailier on va
l'envoyer main droite
le spin 11 passes main gauche on voit
qu'il ya pas d'option un autre fait du
web et cette fois ci ça rentrera pas
donc trop souvent encore pour le moment
il ya ce genre de deux tiers un peu
casse briques là vous voyez on lui donne
une direction franche on veut vraiment
l'envoyer chance à ma gauche du coup il
dribble beaucoup il n'arrive pas à se
trouver un écart il se fait contrer par
tyson qui est un pivot ça c'est quelque
chose qui me posent fortement problème
points niveau supérieur alors l'image je
m'excuse 1 pour la qualité on est sur la
capture de la capture youtube alors
quand un pivot veut tenir certains -
faible ça ça me pose problème
encore une fois ici vous voyez
l'orientation il les orienter ma gauche
non pas sur pick and roll switch
orienté encore ma gauche et repasse ma
droite parce qu'ils n'arrivent pas à
créer un écart est sale oblige du coup à
ce spin move et ya une perte de balle
va pas et je crois que j'en ai un
dernier ici
orienté ma gauche et du coup passage en
force voilà tout simplement donc si
jamais vous l'avez pas
vous n'avez pas compris alors que le
répète 43 fois
on va devoir développer une main faible
on va devoir faire des progrès sur ce
champ fleuri pour être une réelle menace
ballom incident
sur du scouting nba il va il va
clairement se faire exploser
là encore une fois d'être tenus par un
ailier alors le poulpe entre mai
mais c'est vraiment un poulpe qui est
obligé c'est pas un choix qui fait c'est
quelque chose qu'on ne s'oblige à un
switch passe à clemson
et excusez moi j'ai un appel dont je me
mets sans l'ignorer rapidement
et voilà
on va passer maintenant sur le
quai ce que peut faire le joueur en pick
and roll on nba on l'a vu que c'était
une arme obligatoire maintenant pour ans
pour important de balès clip le joueur
plaît quitely peut exister sur pythia
lorsqu on va essayer de voir je vais
laisser tourner en boucle pour vous
donner mon avis dessus et puis après on
fera du ralenti
globalement on aime bien la navigation
du joueur sur pick and roll c'est un
genre qui est assez fluide qui maîtrise
bien son dribble mercredi vers son sont
sa navigation balle en main capable de
gérer le tempo c'est un mec qui est très
bon sur du c'ur du club à mi distance
donc si il a un meilleur pivot il pourra
sanctionner à mi distance soit une
défense d'europe et il ya de plus en
plus de l'effort de drop en saison
régulière ça avec qui
[Musique]
et bonjour drive and click nom qu'on lui
donne un pick and roll et qu'un accès
aux pas ni pour un ticket le ciel jamais
il ya une led qui viennent rotation
défensif libyen qui trouvent qu'il
laissera du coin coquio l'ordre à trois
points dans les coronaires maintenant
c'est un joueur qui va beaucoup raté je
trouve deux passes faciles ce que ce
soit pour un rôle même le soin pour un
joueur en qui tiennent pop il a une
manie vous allez voir ce qu'ils refusent
très souvent l'écran c'est quelque chose
qu'on voit une bille et beaucoup sur un
peuple dit me battrai pour le fait
énormément il ya un écran il va très
très souvent partir dans la direction
opposée à l'écran et essayer de faire un
drive ma droite et ensuite plup sait
quelque chose
vraiment qui est symptomatique diriger
ce jour là
et on va essayer de voir ça du coup dans
le dans les extraits alors des fois il
trouve des bonnes passes et des fois on
voit que c'est pas encore fluide pour
moi ya un vrai travail de vista à faire
ce portail j'y crois pas sûr comme étant
important de balle principal je le vois
pas être le meneur de jeu d'une équipe
malgré sa taille pour l'instant pour moi
c'est plus un porteur de balle
secondaire voire important de balle de
bons + cas puisqu'un réel meneur c'est
un combo mais dans le mauvais sens du
terme pour le moment
on va essayer de regarder ça donc
globalement sur pick'n roll
je peux aller au panier quand je suis ma
droite quand je suis main gauche c'est
plus compliqué j'utilise bien la
longueur je peux surtout le pam et
distant ça je le fais très très bien
j'ai pas pur moment de tirs à trois
points derrière l'écran donc s'il défend
ce fait l'impasse sur son tir ce que ce
qui arrive des jeunes s'il va pas
prendre deux tirs à trois points
derrière l'écran et la vision de jeu et
a développé il ya des bons flashs
notamment drive heynckes qui fait très
bien mais pour un rôle mais nous pour un
pop c'est beaucoup plus faible on va
regarder ça du coup
en clip par clip en vitesse un peu plus
un peu plus longtemps alors on se remet
la
up et on commence par les clips pour lui
même
alors
hop
et c'est parti
alors jamais depuis le début s'cusez moi
moi moi je les rater donc la peace and
roll
vous voyez au délicat c'est de refuser
l'écran il repasse sur sa main gauche et
derrière il rentre dans le court de
koffi cockburn il absorbe le contact est
finie ça c'est quelque chose qu'on
pourra voir en année 2 en année 3
lorsqu'il aura plus de plus de puissance
qui leur a pris dix kilos de pouvoir
rentrer dans les pivots et de finir avec
la cafo de finir au contact des tees et
sa longueur ça c'est vraiment le projet
qu'on veut voir là encore une fois pick
and roll aller chercher la faute m du
contact ça c'est vraiment un axe de
développement
on va aller voir ce clip là on voit
quand je vous dit refuser l'écran c'est
ça il ya un écran pour le mettre ma
droite il refuse l'écran il surprend le
défenseur rod et on a des parts à ma
gauche et avec ma longueur de bras je
peux trouver un lay up facile
autres pick and roll on essaie la
défense essaie de le refuser l'écran est
là donc la défense aisé de contester la
prise de l'écran chant pick and roll pas
de souci pour lui je pars ma gauche
explosif up step
et je finis ma droite
actions suivront donc encore à pick and
roll
cette fois ci je pars main gauche il ya
une bonne aide de la part de la défense
et je suis capable de prendre un poulpe
à mi-distance là dessus je suis en
efficacité je le remercie parce qu' une
bonnette de la défense michael quand
même une belle protection de balle donc
regarder ici je frise
bonehead centrale ça s'il défend ce que
j'aime beaucoup que malheureusement je
ne trouve pas c'est en nba il arrive à
protéger son ballon ne pas se faire
intercepter koffi cockburn est un pivot
classiques d'europe donc est un
protecteur de cercle assez peu mobile
est en bas il redescend et je vais
prendre le pouls l'option de la tête
avec efficacité
donc les actions suivantes picks and
rolls par ma gauche je repasse ma droite
je reviens à ma gauche
une belle patience et je vais aller
trouver une finition près du panier ça
aussi ce qu'il a bien je peux leur
maître sait que c'est un joueur qui est
patient qui est capable de faire sauter
la défense de trouver du coup soit les
iob soit une faute sur une deuxième
attention donc on la remet en vitesse
réelle ici donc moins gauche up feinte
j'ai fait sauter koffi coburn et je
termine en efficacité
ici deux dans le corner
on va venir récupérer là la balle il est
orienté point de main gauche je parle ma
droite je refuse l'écran et avec du
toucher je vais aller finir sur une
sorte de flotteurs main droite
ici pick and roll encore une fois pour
l'appui distance vraiment c'est sa
signature quelque chose qui fait déjà
très très bien et quand une pie ix et il
aura le fantasme des pivots qui switch
c'est vraiment pas une réalité
actuellement on a quand même beaucoup de
pivot qui reste très bas dans les
défenses et fin en saison régulière vous
l'avez vous l'avez tous les ans c'est
pour ça que beaucoup de de porteur de
balle qu'on trouvait pas cette les
icônes israël n'est pas à cette équipe
pour créer un écart il n'y arrivera pas
finalement 6e régulière y dominent je
pense à taïz halliburton ce qui est
vraiment une de mes erreurs de scouting
au début je me disais mais dans les
jours qui arrivent pas se créer un écart
il est passé athlétique mais parce qu'il
a dit très bien parce qu'il a cette arme
à mi distance et qu'il a cette capacité
à passer
de façon supérieure telle mise
halliburton a beaucoup de 10 heures
comme ça va beaucoup de situations
ouverte et du coup on réussit donc les
quitely peut le faire le tir à mi
distance revient on voit phoenix qui est
une des meilleures attaques le fait très
bien chicago le fait beaucoup aussi donc
dans les gros attaque vous avez beaucoup
beaucoup de milles rennes jld
toucs
alors venom je vois que notre botte a
censuré
effectivement on ne rit pas il est
paramétré pour ne pas mettre de liens
dans le chat donc je suis désolé si tu
voulais nous mettre un lien
intéressant tu peux l'envoyer via
twitter et je pourrais essayer de
transmettre ses rapports avec bill
christie mais voilà désolé pour cent on
repart
donc ici se fait contrer parce qu'on
voit qu'il ya un problème au niveau de
la main gauche alors pour le faire
rapidement quand il est sur pick'n roll
et qui va être orientés - gauche il
aurait dû finir de la main gauche il
repasse trop souvent sur sa main droite
malheureusement envoyé l'an l'orientent
main gauche il prend de vitesse le
joueur il doit finir main gauche il
revient - droite et du coup il se fait
contrer donc encore une fois qu'on parle
de développer la mafia menées là-dessus
ici pick and roll je suis patient
j'utilisais ma main gauche moi ce qui me
pose problème quand je vous parle de
vision du jeu c'est que si on échoue à
une situation de piquionne pop qui
pourra voir en nba et il rate totalement
le joueur ouvert donc là hollobone piero
est descendu hyper bas pour contester
vous avez un tir à trois points on
verrait si avec un joueur qui peut
sanctionner et bhl equis lit et dans ce
tunnel vision il quitte bien choix les
côtés mais en pick and go pirates
souvent
le posant d'écran et du coup on aurait
pu avoir un tir ouvert et on finit avec
un lay up raté
alors la réaction suivante au niveau du
clip donc sa galère totalement je suis
désolé pour celui-là je vous le remet
on a scellé philippe qui marche pas tant
pis par
toute la
on revient encore une fois cette fois ci
une bonne lecture hélas le pick and pop
il est réussi
nous voilà ya des flashes à la passe qui
me font dire que ça peut devenir un pro
tour de boeuf secondaire mais il n'est
pas assez fluide pour le moment potable
dans des bols principal on rappelle
qu'au bewise à trois employés
travaillent ils avaient le même problème
on se disait que oui ça pouvait être un
jour de drive et xterra mais finalement
il a jamais réussi à passer le cap et
ces troubles et kouici
de pâtre capable aussi de de passer de
capdevilla vous voyez d une bonne
spasmes et le le timing est tellement
lent c'est pas du tout en fluidité je
vous la remet
ya beaucoup trop d'hésitation pour que
ça puisse marcher en nba donc là et ma
gauche un espace qui est créé jeu freeze
et ne passe ici a affaire au sol vous
avez la bonne spassky et là il
finalement il attend il attend et il la
transmet mais bien trop tard pour que ce
soit une passe réussie l'orientent main
gauche et encore une fois il rate
totalement la transmission ici on peut
se voir faire
au ralenti
orientation main gauche
la défense fait n'importe quoi vous avez
mon invité au 26 bonnes que j'aime très
fort ici il ya vraiment un espace énorme
y passe à transmettre là on est moins
gauche pas capable de passer à une main
gauche et le joueur se retrouve ouvert
mais la passe n'arrivera jamais
qu'ils tiennent rôle ma droite cette
fois ci il ya de la passe qui est
transmise alors en terme de timing elle
n'est pas parfaite elle est faite un peu
tôt 7 passes mais au moins elle mérite
d'être là donc là il ya un écran on
aurait pu normalement avoir une passe
dans laxe dans la course pour que le
joueur n'est pas à dribbler autant pour
ce accéder un accès au panier on
l'envoie par dessus un peu trop et il ya
deux dribbles à faire pour avoir une
finition donc ça c'est une passe qui
finit pas une passe décisive mais qui
est pas une bonne passe ce drame heure
de jeu encore une fois ici à rolle ci
est ratée avec un joueur frustré au
niveau de son coéquipier parfait
qui tiennent roll mon l'écran est mal
posée et vous avez une passe ici dans
laxe complètement vers ya pas de
couverture défensive côté faible et la
passe n'arrivera jamais voilà
ça c'est pour notre ami play quitely
bas-normands nous
jour de pick and roll oui pour lui-même
oui genre de dryden qui croquait mais
pour l'instant dans la création
collective en tant que meneur de jeu
pour faire jouer à big ben non c'est pas
encore en place on va les avoir sur son
tir maintenant est ce que le joueur est
capable on a vu qu'ils avaient une
rigueur une réussite intel sont à mi
distance mais à trois points que c'était
pas ça qu'est ce que ça donne alors 31%
beaucoup de catch and shoot je vous ai
mis des séquences de catch and shoot
on voit qu'en termes de mécanique c'est
auquel le le geste il est fluide la
balle est un peu poussé en avant
quand il rentre dans le ballon il est
plus en efficacité
pour l'instant n'y a pas la capacité à
pouvoir créer son propre tir à trois
points depuis depuis le dribble on voit
aussi que le joueur est puissant
efficacité lorsque la balle arrive
directement sa main droite ça marche ça
m'arrive de shoot la balle affirme ahmad
chose il peut s'élever directement et
sanctionnés mais lorsque la balle avec
jean sa main gauche qui te vois du goût
repasser réaxer ma droite et s'est levé
ses bons plans en difficulté
là vous le voyez sur du pool up le tir
est assez poussé en avant vous avez un
manque d'équilibré au niveau des pieds
les pièces sont partants d'avant aussi
donc c'est un joueur qui a un tir qui
n'est pas encore
stabilisée
lorsqu'il est en équilibre il est
efficace lorsqu'il est en
déséquilibre qui arrive trop souvent
il manque d'efficacité donc est-ce que
je crois dans le tir à terme oui moi
j'ai envie de dire que oui parce qu'une
mécanique qui est vraiment pas mal et
qu'on voit qu'il est capable de créer de
l'écart maintenant est ce qu'il est
capable de sanctionner à trois points ce
thème bac etc j'en suis moins sûr et
puis je vous ai mis aussi peut-être que
action loin du ballon dans des quêtes et
sait pas ce qui peut se rendre
disponible même si c'est vraiment un
secteur
minoritaire de son jeu pour aller sur le
tir dont je vous en mets ici parce que
les matériaux vous voyez la balle alors
je vais le mettre au ralenti
up alone
ici les mâles sont prêtes la balle
arrive ma droite est donc très vite je
peux réaxer armée déclenchée avec une
mécanique rapide
quand je suis dans laxe balle arrive ma
droite et que je rentre dans la balle
c'est pareil je suis en efficacité
[Musique]
maintenant faut je trouve l'exemple la
balle elle arrive sur sa main gauche
hop
donc là encore une fois on arrive ma
droite mais lui ne rentre pas mais quand
alpha sa main gauche voilà il prend du
temps à remettre dans l'axé et du coup
il est bien plus en difficulté et sur le
pool up alors le lancer franc on a vu ce
que ça prendrait le site ce qui est pas
bien du tout mécaniquement la pointe des
pieds un jour qui trichent sur la pointe
des pieds
mais moi je suis pas un expert là-dessus
faudra demander à nicolas lang ou bien
pierre qui se connaît mieux que moi je
vous le dire vous voyez dans le pool up
c'est très poussée en avant et les
jantes sont très désaxé ont leur messie
mais hop là
j'allaite frise au bon moment
donc là dans le dribble
donc voyez on se pousse en avant et les
pieds par devoir et man grand écart en
équerre
et il ya un manque défilant se tient là
et du coup pas d'efficacité
qui chante en titre n roll
on repasse ma droite et encore une fois
un tiers très en déséquilibre cette fois
ci rentre mais c'est globalement la vue
31% il ya peu d'efficacité chance et de
servage crois qu'il a moins de 25% sur
le pull up
à trois temps voilà
défensivement enfin pour terminer je
pour ses joueurs
s'il nous disait
un peu là
potentiel défensif potentiel défensif
par sa longueur par sa mobilité par le
fait qu'ils pensent qu'on pourra
rajouter alors je pense qu'il le met la
voilà
pouvoir rajouter de la masse sur le haut
du corps en question le contact belle
intensité
pour être un peu plus fléchi afin de
mieux cadrer les habitants d'al masara
direct vous voyez que steve il travaille
dans le basket avec les y'a un avis qui
est vraiment pointu ça fait ça fait
plaisir vigilant des forces non porteurs
concernés souvent place dans les aides
et peut défendre efficacement les lignes
de passes alors moi je tousse à la
touche volleyée ne pas suis d'accord
c'est un joueur qui va jouer très
souvent l'interception on le voit il est
à une virgule 7 ce titre par un match
qui va être une virgule de ses parts et
il joue très souvent la ligne de passe
maintenant
sur la
sur la défense direct moi j'ai un
problème quand même c'est au niveau
encore une fois de l'implication charpy
tient drôle je trouve que très souvent
sur pick'n roll il se fait prendre dans
il n'est pas attentif et des fois ya un
manque il ya un manque de concentration
et c'est ce qu'on va pouvoir voir ici on
est sur un potentiel défensif par la
longueur
de bras par effectivement la rotation
c'est un joueur qui est point dans les
rotations par la lecture des lignes de
passes mais ça implique qui fait du
cambodge et donc ça implique souvent ils
créent des situations de surcharge pour
l'attack en étant hors de position
donc ici ce que j'aime bien c'est que
latéralement alors ils échangent un
extérieur europe
latéralement vous voyez que il tient
bien les pièges bien il encaisse bien le
contact il va orienter pour amener
jusqu'au cercle on me l'a aussitôt mais
de l'agressivité sur la balle on
encaisse le contact et là on conteste
avec les deux mains même jour à jour
plus physique capable de contester
moindrement tester main gauche on va
être très dissuasif on va être très
agressif dans les hand of dans les
lignes de passes et avec sa longue on va
aller chercher des styles c'est quelque
chose qui fait très très bien il a une
belle anticipation des lignes de passes
qui comprend bien soin de la rotation
défensive il vient souvent en aide il
reste verticale près du cercle donc
c'est un joueur qui va être intéressant
son style sur ce secteur là mais a
contrario
on voit aussi qu'il ya encore un
problème pour encaisser le contact sur
des profils d'arrière assez puissant il
se fait rentrer dans l'éboulis il va
jusqu'au cercle et le fait de vouloir
gumbel ça fait des fois il laisse passer
son défenseur enfin son attaquant par
non et du coup il revient pas derrière
et je repique n roll une fois qu'il est
battu il est assez nonchalant donc il ya
des ce genre de choses là à travailler
maintenant on va pouvoir les jours du
clip un peu plus
que moi dira un peu plus individuelle
donc ici
hop là
donc je passe sous l'écran latéralement
et une belle mobilité au niveau des feux
niveau des appuis je restais verticale
je conteste le tir sans provoquer de
faut donc ça il le fait très très bien
avec sa longueur sur pick and roll lie à
un switch agressif on voir et les mains
donc les pièces sont bien placés mais la
main elle et hop on va mettre un peu de
pression sur ballons gagnés mois sept
longueurs tentaculaire au niveau de son
bras quelque chose de très différent
les pieds bougeait bien on anticipe bien
le drive je tiens au contact je change
de main ici parce que je sais que je
peux avoir un bras roulé j'oriente
et je vais contester finalement à la fin
le fait de wells il ya une très bonne
lecture défensive ya une très bonne
gestion de l'orientation défensive
sur ce jour là là on va aller casser je
vous le disais le n9 par sa longueur je
rentre dans le hand of avec ma longueur
de bras je crée du coup ne stimule
transition et je peux aller finir en
dunkant simplement au panier ça elle le
fait très très bien aussi
ici en lecture de lignes de passe donc
on vient aider il lit tout de suite la
passe c'était du football américain et
après par mon dribble j'arrive à me dois
me séparer de la défense et je crée une
transition
donc là il est pris dans l'écran alors
pour une fois que mark williams pose un
bon écran mais je reste agressif je
reviens
au contact et du coup je ne parle même
pas d'avoir surcharge quand il fait ça
je l'achète 100%
mais il ya des fois il beaucoup de fois
il le fait pas maintenant transition et
iv fini j'arrête pas il n'arrive pas à
arrêter le ballon il se fait battre en
physique et du coup derrière arrive à
créer un lay up facile donc là dessus
quand je dis faut qu'il prenne de la
masse corporelle est cohérent processus
de très draft pour un joueur qui sera
prêt dans deux trois ans typiquement cfa
là on vous voyez on va aller tenter
l'interception me suis battu et derrière
n'y a pas d'efforts y'a vraiment il joue
déjà le la transition des attaques de
l'autre côté comment un lycéen et ça
alors il a de la chance parce que ça
rentre pas à mes sens au niveau nba sera
pas pardonnable
là il est face à des 26 bonnes qui est
important de balle très puissant très
explosif que j'aime beaucoup battu sur
le pick and rolls un bon écran mais ya
pas d il n'y a pas de tentatives pour
revenir derrière il reste bas depuis là
tant que l'action est finie
ici ça va être la même chose
donc des relents de six mois rappelle le
pitch and roll je conteste je me fais
prendre dans l'écran et j'attends que ça
se passe
et je vais pas venir à derrière proposer
une solution une rotation proposer un
repli intéressant voilà donc c'est un
joueur qui est très jeune aussi bien
physiquement que dans sont plus dans son
basket qui va devoir gagne en maturité
on stabilité en physicalité
comptera sur drafté pré draft et pour
avoir dans un deux trois ans à pourvoir
dans deux trois ans un joueur nba on va
laisser faire des erreurs ou jig à
l'image d'un rachat primo actuellement
du côté de des spurs qui alterne entre
la dgi digues et qui a un peu de temps
de jeu en nba et on voit qui fait des
belles choses déjà on va laisser le
temps de faire des erreurs
je pense que le projet c'est d'avoir un
porteur de balle secondaire d'avoir un
mec qui va pouvoir créer son propre
décalage et prendre des tirs qui va
pouvoir se charger à terme du meilleur
porteur de balle adverses en défense et
avec sa longueur venir créer un problème
est ce que c'est un titulaire nba ce
serait pour moi son plafond je ne vois
pas être annuler star ou quoi que ce
soit parce que
je trouve qu'il ya un trop gros
attachant la main gauche pour que ce
soit vraiment possible de refaire 1-1 et
le rôle star
ya ya un fantasme du développement du
dribbleur certains prospects qui moi
m'interroge je pense que quand on a cet
âge-là 19 ans et qu'on est si si comment
dire si latéralisé sur une main forte et
c'est très difficile de créer un dribble
sur une main faible donc le dessus j'y
crois pas mais voilà en avoir un bon
défenseur dans l'équipe s'il faut que le
tir rentrer avoir un bon supporter de
balle tout ça qu'on achète donc moi je
l'est en fin de 1er tour en espérant
qu'ils tombent pas dans une équipe trop
compétitive qu'il le fera pas jouer du
tout qui comptera pas dessus qui s'en
servira en disant je le draff parce que
j'ai j'ai un pic au delà du potentiel à
la nba tout y est ce que l'an dernier
les clippers je m'acharne sur eux ont
fait avec aaron johnson par exemple et
heureusement le mec ce fait transféré du
côté des blazers j'espère que dans une
équipe qui sera patiente avec lui il y
aura un vrai projet donc je pense que
c'est même mieux qu'ils soient draft et
enfin de loterie
comme ce que alan alexandrie cratère a
omis de kiss face drafté là où moi je
l'attends sur son niveau réel en 25 ans
votre 20 et 30 et qu'il puisse jamais
joué jamais se développer voilà j'espère
que j'ai été assez clair sur ce joueur
n'hésitez pas à le regarder a comparé
les avis sur tout à lire ce que
alexandrie escaladant disent que steve
andy et cetera aller voir chaude et
votre caste us et tout
je pense que c'est un joueur qui s'il a
une promesse au premier tour il ira même
s'il n'est pas prêt financièrement
parlant c c'est vraiment irréaliste de
penser que le mec tout je suis un
premier tour
voilà si une équipe a une idée un projet
style san antonio pourquoi mais c'est un
mec faudra pas se mettre sur précis il
est drafté vous voyez pas pendant deux
ans et que d'un coup il surgit et qu'il
devient fort c'est voilà c'est l'idée ce
projet f du show prime